so world leaders have been caught on a
candid video recording mocking Donald
Trump and while Republicans are
absolutely outraged at the fact that
there was a recording there is nothing
at all surprising about this and I'm
going to explain why to you today
besides the obvious reasons as you know
if you've been paying attention to
politics and you're not blinded by
partisanship or ignorance Donald Trump
has made the United States the
laughingstock of the world and has
caused the u.s. to not be taken
seriously on a whole host of issues at
the top of the list of course climate
change but also trade foreign policy
within geopolitical alliances and in the
context of treaties being close to the
top of the list in sort of a shared way
Trump is not invited to lots of
important conversations on these issues
Trump has often been condescended to at
meetings of world leaders and there have
been pictures of Trump being talked to
like he's a little kid in a roomful of
world leaders now this is all public any
sensible person would guess that in
private world leaders are absolutely
sick of Trump well Trump is now at the
NATO summit in the UK I'll have more
coverage of that later in the show and
world leaders were caught on a candid
video a sort of hot mic moment if you
will clearly ridiculing Donald Trump and
his behavior this video which we're
going to play as Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau French President Emmanuel
macron and Trump like British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson when even Boris
Johnson is part of a crowd making fun of
you you know that you are an
international laughingstock here's the
video you'll hear them talking about
Trump being late about his ridiculous
press conferences about how Trump
staffers jaws hit the floor because of
Trump's behavior now I do apologize to
people if you're merely listening it is
a little bit tough to hear it all
clearly for our video audience it is
subtitled let's take a look
it's beer
[Music]
again when even Boris Johnson is
laughing at you you are the
laughingstock and this is a real change
for the American presidency for the
office of the presidency I'm talking
about here and I hate to see this I
really do I you know there are people
who say oh the left wants the the
economy to crash just to spite Trump or
they want the u.s. to be a laughing
stock just to spite Trump I hate this
this is horrible to see Barack Obama
disagree with his policies on many
issues he was respected internationally
he was an adult in the room he was
leading conversations of world leaders
as opposed to either being condescended
to or ignored or left out altogether I
just wish the trumpets were honest with
us admit Trump is a laughingstock and
that the u.s. is not respected but tell
us you don't care to pretend that
everybody around the world respects
Trump fears Trump it's absurd just tell
us you don't care that he's a laughing
US rat a laughingstock rather than
denying the reality Trump campaigned on
everyone is laughing at Obama and if I'm
president we're going to be respected
again as usual the opposite of trumps
campaign framing ended up being the
reality and in any case this is just one
piece of it there are lots of very
relevant things already to discuss from
the NATO summit which we're going to get
to momentarily but once again we are not
in a position of strength when world
leaders are talking together and
laughing at the President of the United
States it could not be more of a
difference from when Barack Obama was
president and again it's really
important to distinguish that doesn't
mean I agreed with Barack Obama on every
policy quite the opposite this doesn't
mean that Barack Obama was pushing the
right policy in all of those
geopolitical summits and meetings
sometimes he was sometimes he wasn't but
we weren't a laughingstock
we now are it's embarrassing it's
medic and it is not going to change not
just until Trump is removed from office
but for a while since Donald Trump has
been removed from office